rescissions issues will be among the
topics as the house begins its business
in about two fifty minutes at ten
o'clock Eastern Time the Senate will get
underway with a striker replacement at
nine-thirty coming up in about 20
minutes 9 30 east coast time 630 for
those of you on the west coast and our
companion app which he's been too as
always we'll have live gavel-to-gavel
coverage of the senate proceedings
martin scorsese yes film director
welcome to Washington thank you what
brings you to town well today at
eleven-thirty will be doing a press
conference introducing two bills that
have to do with motion picture industry
the first is the national film disc
could be film disclosure act 1995 and
the other is the motion picture
authorship Act and you hope to
accomplish what well for the first we're
dealing with in the film disclosure act
what we feel is needed on films that
have been changed I'm films that have
been changed for television or on
airlines and edited in any way or a time
compressed or images which have been
compressed to fit the screen we would
like labeling on those films for the
audience watching the presentation to
understand that the original authors of
the picture did not necessarily agree
with these changes so therefore they're
not really watching the original you
know what they're watching is a version
of that original film and we're talking
about also colorization that the film is
originally shot in black and white what
we feel is important is to change the
thinking and to make people understand
that there are human beings behind this
movie that there is no it the way the
way the labels are presented today their
innocence almost misleading that in a
way you get a sense of ism strange
overall corporation or corporate body
behind the making of this picture so
that it's not specific it's not on a
human level what we're really talking
about is taking motion pictures and
raising the level of respect respect and
integrity of probably the greatest
indigenous American art form
and giving it the level of respect that
it deserves now in 1995 which is the
hundredth anniversary of the invention
of motion pictures as is the perfect
time to to begin to literally change the
thinking about what goes behind this and
literally take pride in a patrimony
which is so extraordinary who's joining
you in this on each side of the aisle on
on the film disclosure act senator
Simpson and Congressman Frank and on the
second on the second motion picture
authorship act as congressman Bryant
Vanity Fair has a piece that we're gonna
show our viewers as well we talked just
before you came on about some of the
projects that you're working on we're
also going to take viewer calls in just
a few minutes so if you want a phone and
we'll show you those numbers mr.
Scorsese will be with us for about ten
minutes then he's heading up to the hill
but Vanity Fair has Casino Royale it's
the new film that you're working on well
casino not Casino Royale but that a
headline of the article that's the
article is uniroyal yes those are
photographs I took on the set
photographs of sharon stone and robert
de niro and Joe Pesci and De Niro what's
the film about if it isn't obvious well
it's about pretty wild time in vegas in
the decade the 70s which ends around the
story ends were 1983 or so from the
moment you get an idea the script to
begin work on the film to the time it
hits the movie theater what on average
what's the time frame these days it's
unfortunately about two years two years
every time I make a picture this is what
we're talking about and why make a
picture you put in so much work and so
much time and actually put your soul and
your blood into it so that when it is
altered you want the audience to
understand that an original copy exists
somewhere that they're not watching the
original the response from the industry
has been difficult because they believe
that people when they see the specific
labeling will not want to watch the film
but don't believe that's true if I know
that I've watched many films edited for
television on TV and knowing that it's
not the original we're also approaching
a period where a witness far as gum
we're so much work can be done digitally
on film that you're never really many
generations removed you're never really
going to know what was the original
unless someone preserves that original
unless there's a stamp of authorship
that a stamp of what the ship and a
stamp of authenticity to say this was
the original negative this was the way
it was originally photographed these are
the original actors the digitalization
today you're not able to tell what's
changed and this is a very dangerous
time because who knows more libraries
could be sold into the hands of other
governments other countries and then 100
200 years from now the film is altered
so that no generation will understand
the new generations will not understand
what the original intent was and I'm
also sort of a history buff in the sense
that you learn a great deal about a
culture from the way they live from the
movies that they watch are the books
they read in the 19th century you really
do learn a great deal and even in a
sense not making value judgments films
or projects that you think may not be
may not be a top level an a product you
find that 20 years later several B
movies quote unquote B movies have
influenced a whole generation of
filmmakers or writers where's home for
you where'd you grow in new york
manhattan how many films have you done i
think about 17 or so your favorite i did
one of my mother and father called
italian-american which was sort of a
documentary about an hour long i
basically was my mother and father
having din I was having dinner with them
and I just kept asking them questions
about how they grew up how they met what
life was like back in the 20s and 30s
they were born in 1912 1913 on Elizabeth
Street in New York where I grew up and I
learned a lot about the Met day and I
also learned a lot about again history
of the American immigrant in a way the
people who immigrated to this country
you know Martin Scorsese is in town for
a news conference that will happen on
Capitol Hill later this morning time for
your phone calls Richmond Virginia good
morning good
morning mr. Scorsese yes one of
America's national treasures I called
asked you if you were trying to write
for the screen for sort of the first
time what sort of things would you read
whose titles who's written good
informative stuff on on how to actually
write for the screen on a technical
basis I'll hang up and listen that's
kind of a kind of an interesting
question because back in the 60s there
was a wonderful book by a lie us b roll
be iro as first name is la j 000 s I
believe called the art of screenwriting
I was like that was a text book that we
used back in New York University when I
went to film school there at that time
it's really it's there's also there's
there are a number of books that you can
get literally they can show you the
structure of a screenplay I think it's
very important and when we rights for
screenplays one doesn't think in terms
of theater what doesn't think in terms
of the traditional one-act 2x and 3x
even though that's that's commonly
talked about in Hollywood these days and
third act of this movie is not working
it's very difficult because in a sense
of movies usually usually composed maybe
two-hour film is sometimes composed of
five or six sequences and within those
sequences there are five or six scenes
and they have a progression of their own
I would tend to to steer more towards
learning how to deal with telling a
story through images rather than through
through something which is based on a
stage bound stage mount approach which
it's not necessarily bad either I mean
if you get a strong drama that can move
people and if it's three people talking
in a room for two hours say that's
pretty good you know if it works it's
where it works but I always try to tell
people to try to look I think in visual
terms and you may need less dialogue you
know it's it's not there's anything
wrong with dialogue but it's a matter of
of really writing for the screen it's
very different from ready for the stage
another call Erie Pennsylvania good
morning
I just have a question I'm a mother of
two boys and I think a lot of the
concerns these days are on values and
how the movie industry NTV reflects a
lot of the values out there do you feel
responsible at all as a director to make
films and to save it things that you
have responsibility for on film have
moral standards to them or because that
we see so much that adultery is this
kind of commonplace premarital sex is
very common and a lot of stout here
think that maybe people in those
positions could be a little more
responsible about reflecting what's more
I don't know what your personal
religious affiliation is you said your
mom and dad were Italian I think people
really need to need to be more
responsible about that can you answer
that question please yes I I understand
I understand your concern my approach I
can only talk to talk about it from my
approach which is that I usually tend to
I tend to gravitate towards stories
which deal with the characters who do
very bad things really and have very
great flaws in them and what I hope what
I hope is understood the audience
viewing the picture is that they watch
the journey of this person or these
people and their lifestyle for example
Goodfellas which which at some point was
quite controversial in the sense that it
appeared to make the aspiring young
gangsters look look positive it look
like a positive lifestyle now if you
watch the film carefully it's two hour
and 20 minutes you for the first hour
everybody's having a lot of fun but I
think it's important that you stay for
the whole movie for the next hour and 20
minutes they pay for it and in a sense
it's almost like being attracted to
Bible stories of the old testament where
you see figures from that from the Bible
literally offending God or or or and
then the sense for the very first story
Lucifer and pride and how he was cast
out of heaven I mean this is the idea I
think I think you could learn more you
could tell a better moral story if you
see and if you understand that they pay
for it
the people pay for it at the end and the
final analysis some people pay for it
and and are reborn they they redeemed
themselves some just don't some just
don't it's a very tricky issue I mean
we're today television and the images
and now at the with computers the
internet this home in the cyberspace
there's so much that we're going to be
bombarded with it's very difficult to to
put restraint on everyone / every person
who sets out to to tell a story with
film or I know what the next media
really is going to be like with
computers and internet you can make up
your own stories then which then you're
not talking about film anymore you're
talking about another whole issue but I
believe that I'm responsible that way
now others may not agree with me on that
but I believe I'm responsible that way
and I find it more I find it more
powerful to tell a story that that is
entertaining in the sense that villains
sometimes could be very entertaining you
like to see what the villain does more
than what the hero is going to do at a
certain point in certain kinds of
stories but then to see how it Howard
Howard how it literally how they want to
pay for it is is very very important and
I have to get going let's grab one more
call if we could to Walnut Creek
California thanks for waiting hi my name
is Maria I just want to say yeah mr.
Sadie it's an honor to speak to you you
produced two of my favorite films the
one about your parents I just happened
to see by accident on Bravo one night
and I was fascinated by it and the other
one is good fellows and I wonder why you
changed the name from the book I had a
difficult time realizing at first that
it was the same movie at the book what
had happened was that there was a
television show called wiseguy a series
which was on every week and it was a
great deal of confusion about that so we
used another term that that these these
guys apparently call each other so that
was a we felt at first it was we were
disappointed but actually turned to be a
very interesting title so Jackson
Heights New York you are last call go
ahead
a good morning mrs. Claus AZ I've
enjoyed your movies absolutely
incredible the age of innocence the
Goodfellas I was wondering your and of
Italian descent and you you put Italians
in such a bad light with all these
movies I worked in construction my whole
life and every Italian that I work with
they always try to associate themselves
with the Cosa Nostra the Mafia and most
Italians that i know of great intellect
and great prestige these people are
Anatomy to them I was wondering could
you give me a little bit of insight how
you actually think about these people
I'll hang up and let you Thank You
caller that's a very good question i
mean being italian-american one has to
realize growing up as an
italian-american i want us to realize
that these these people are around us
and as a child growing up I didn't know
the difference at the age of eight seven
or eight years old between one of these
people one of these guys and the fellow
is who is really a hard-working guy you
know I'm a working stiff in a way in a
way I just I just related to them as
people and later as I found out what
they did I became fascinated with the
idea of how some of them could be
actually very nice people they were
really treating me very well took care
of me when I was a child and I'm
fascinated by the dichotomy there how
they can do such evil things they could
be how they could be a so brutal in a
way and yet be gentle and at times this
is a phenomena that is always fascinated
me I mean there's no doubt my probably
used to say tomatoes don't have don't
ever go near them he said they have
their blood suckers in that way they'll
they'll take everything from you and
it's it was a warning throughout my
whole life that that I had to live with
and I
that doesn't mean that they can't be
excellent subjects two to four films or
four books you for you to understand a
little more about the human condition
and say it's a I'm just trying to deal
what I know to be the truth from where I
come from final question how would you
summarize the relationship between
hollywood in Washington well I think
it's really interesting and night the
the there was actually an act passed the
National Film Preservation Act a few
years ago which actually for the first
time establishes officially that motion
pictures are an art form and this is a
really good step I think it's going to
take a long time a lot of discussion a
lot of debate a long time to protect
motion pictures but I think quite
honestly in the past few years of coming
down here with the Directors Guild of
America and all of that and the Writers
Guild is very important very important
to see such goodwill towards towards the
industry or at least at least to listen
to what we have to say and that's been
very very hopeful Martin Scorsese is now
working on his new film casino with Joe
Pesci sharon stone and robert de niro in
town for news conference later this
morning it will be held on Capitol Hill
yes thank you very much thanks very much
for joining us thank you